what's up there chef how you doing okay  gosh do not do this to me  I still want another child and my  husband is like no we have four oh my  gosh so oh so cute I know this is a  weird statement but I kind of want to  eat your baby it's so cute  all right kind of always near a kitchen  are you near your kitchen right now I am  I'll quickly take you in there because  this is the sort of the hot zone so let  me in the kitchen here is that over here  so she has what they call an amazing  sweet potato and veggies for Oscars  dinner  she's been she from the canned I love  your accent like your baby he's in the  kitchen with these pots and pans it baby  fever when you see them and you're like  oh I missed the chubby little legs and a  little please subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel please  don't make me keep going